In this last lesson of the course,
I want to provide a brief and
high-level overview of some of the
technical challenges and technologies
that are relevant to today's internet
scale applications that are popular.
And the underlying data center
systems that support their execution.
Please note my emphasis on brief and
high-level.
The space of data center technologies is
so vast and so dynamic, that there is no
way we can cover it in sufficient
technical depth in just one lesson.
In fact, there are a number
of courses at Georgia Tech
that devote a substantial percentage
of their content to these topics.
Instead what I want to achieve with this
lesson, is to make sure I provide you
with some context so that you can
understand how some of the mechanisms
that were discussed earlier in this
course, apply to those problems,
to those technologies that
are in popular use today.
Specifically we will describe
the typical multi-tier architectures for
supporting internet skill services and
applications, and
their related management challenges.
Next we will talk about cloud computing.
We will explain what it is and
what is the role that it plays
in addressing the limitations of some
of these traditional approaches.
And finally we will briefly comment on
some of the key technologies that shape
the cloud computing landscape, and
that enable us, with scale and
flexibility, in how we process
large amounts of information.